hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll here's a
question of interest how hard is it to
solve a problem that seems like a very
important question right especially when
we're faced with all sorts of very
difficult problems
socially biologically planet airily and
so forth but it's also a very hard
question to answer in itself right like
what do you mean how hard it is what
kind of problems are you talking about
happily computer scientists have a very
specific field of problems the specific
kind of problems and they care a lot
about how hard they are to solve there's
a whole field of endeavor called
theoretical computer science you can be
a world leading theoretical computer
scientist and never actually program a
computer although today's guest is not
in that category one of the things that
theoretical computer scientists worry
about is if you have a certain kind of
problem like sorting a list into
alphabetical order how many steps does
your computer program have to take to
solve that problem and how do the number
of steps depend on the size of the list
this is the problem known as
computational complexity and today's
guest Scott Aaronson is one of the
world's experts in this field in fact I
feel bad even about saying this Scott is
a computer scientist at the University
of Texas at Austin who is not only one
of the world's experts in theoretical
computer science and computational
complexity but seems to be the world's
expert in many different fields so today
we're gonna dive into things like P
versus NP right this is a famous problem
about whether or not a problem that is
easy to check the solution for is also
easy to solve almost no one thinks it's
true yet it turns out to be really
really hard to show it we're gonna go
into quantum complexity theory which
then gets you into the question of if
you built a quantum computer would it be
able to speed up hard problems that we
know about like factoring large numbers
as Scott will tell us many of the claims
you may have heard about the potential
for quantum computers speeding things up
tend to be a little bit exaggerated
there really are speed ups available but
maybe not as many as you heard about and
on the other hand we've had a real
difficulty in proving
any of these results there's a long list
of things that we believe are true and
haven't yet proven it's a very fruitful
area to go in for a young person who
really wants to make a mark on a new and
emerging field but also once you get
into quantum mechanics you're gonna
become interested in things like quantum
gravity right I mean who could possibly
avoid that so it's god I talk about
black holes and the holographic
principle and complementarity and how
we've somehow gotten quantum information
into the game of trying to understand
the fundamental makeup of the universe
Scott is a long-term friend of mine a
collaborator on fun papers and
everyone's favorite go-to guy when you
talk about these issues and if you
listen to this podcast you will find out
why if you don't know let me remind you
that here during our lockdown as long as
it's still going on I'm doing a set of
weekly videos called the biggest ideas
in the universe right now we're about 10
videos in and we're in the middle of a
pretty intense couple weeks trying to
understand quantum field theory Fineman
diagrams stuff like that there's no
mathematical background presumed but you
have to be willing to go along with me
on some pretty heady ideas so check
those out there on YouTube just go to
youtube and search for my name or
biggest ideas in the universe we're
gonna be getting to some even bigger
ideas the idea is just getting bigger
and bigger that's what we're gonna do so
we haven't done gravity or quantum
gravity yet but believe me we will get
there before too long I hope you're
enjoying them hope that everyone is
staying healthy and sane and safe during
this weird situation we're in and let's
go
[Music]
Scott Aaronson welcome to the lionsgate
podcast thanks it's great to be here
you know I am I recently became an
external professor at the Santa Fe
Institute and for their their focus is
complexity studies and I remember like
back in the 90s this used to be a huge
thing defining what a complex system
actually was and it took me a while to
catch on that people like you have a way
of using the word complexity that
doesn't have anything to do with any of
the complex systems
they're talking about so what do you
mean when you talk about complexity yes
it's it's an overloaded term all right
the definition of complexity is complex
one of these one of these self
describing words like you know short
short okay but uh in in theoretical
computer science what people mean by
complexity would say by computational
complexity is the resources that are
needed to solve some problem and
specifically what we care about is the
scaling of the resources so the the most
common resources that you might worry
about are how much time does your
program take and how much memory does it
use right time in space right those are
pretty fundamental you could worry about
other things also like how much random
how many random bits do you need how
many parallel processors do you need do
you need a quantum computer you know
what kind of what's the physical
substrate of your computer how many
qubits how many classical bits but you
know we're we're not so interested in
just giving answers like oh you know I
can I can solve problems of size a
thousand using a 30 K of RAM right say
and and some problems of size 2,000
using 50 K you know because that's kind
of like okay great but you know tomorrow
someone might have a slightly better
idea and it'll just cut that number by a
factor of 10 or you know I mean I mean
these numbers are you know they're not
fundamental features of the universe
right or or of math they're you know
they depend enormous
on details of what machine you're using
right of course a faster computer will
be able to do the same thing but faster
and you know and so forth what we really
care about is you know how is the how
are the resources like time or memory
growing as you go to larger and larger
problem sizes okay so for example if I
ask you to tell me you know whether a
number is prime or composite right then
we could say the input size is just the
length of the number all right how many
digits it takes to write it down and
what we really like is to have an
algorithm to solve that kind of problem
that would use resources time and memory
that grow only like the size of the
problem raised to some fixed power okay
so like the number of digits cubed
something that's actually
state-of-the-art algorithms for prime
allottee testing that's about how much
time they do use okay what we don't want
is an algorithm you that uses resources
that grow exponentially with the size of
the problem right and the reason I mean
I mean no I I have this whole mini
lecture about you know explaining
exponential growth but I feel like in
the age of coronavirus that might not
even be necessary you know now you know
maybe you know if there's one good thing
to come out of this maybe people now
understand it better is you know animals
yeah exactly that an exponential will
you know by the time you're at problems
of size a thousand or thousand digit
numbers that you'd already be talking
like you know longer than the age of the
universe to solve it you know even if
you got had every atom in the observable
universe you know working on your
problem in parallel so it's something
that exponentially hard then we say it's
really really hard and if it's only
exactly Noemie little bit then we say
it's easy yes so in in practice this
tends to be the dividing line that that
we focus on you know is is is your
problem solvable by some algorithm that
has only polynomial scaling or there's
every possible algorithm require
exponential
scale it okay now there are intermediate
possibilities you know there are
functions that grow faster than
polynomial and slower than exponential
there are you know and and of course
even among you know polynomials if it
grew like the problem size to the 1000
power well that's technically probably
Gnomeo but that's not very good right
but you know but it but but in practice
you know usually if you can solve your
problem by some method with
Exponential's I'm sorry by split by some
algorithm with polynomial scaling then
usually you know if you put enough
effort into it you know if you care
enough it like problem size to the
hundred can become problem size to the
ten can become problem size the three or
to the four whereas if every algorithm
you can find has exponential scaling
then you're just kind of hosed that's
kind of saying that like you don't know
anything better than some brute force
approach that involves just trying every
possible answer from some astronomically
large space of possibilities and he's
got a polynomial algorithm yeah so it
seems to me that a lot of the bread and
butter of a working complexity theorist
in your sense in the theoretical
computer science a sense is the best
existing algorithm takes n bits and
solves the problem in n to the two point
four power steps but I can find an
algorithm that does it in end to the two
point three power steps in L I am the
winner yeah that is certainly a game
that people play right or even to
improve end to the two point four to n
to the two point four divided by log of
n or something like that right that is
you know that's a little bit look down
upon just shaving logs off okay but so
so yes so so so basically we want to
know you know for for various important
problems you know by important problems
like let's say multiplying numbers right
yeah multiplying matrices you know
telling whether a number is prime
deciding the truth or falsehood of a you
know
sentence and mathematical logic or you
know a scheduling right uh
scheduling airline flights you know not
that anyone's doing that right now
you know you know uh figuring out how a
protein will fall that might you know uh
fight the coronavirus something where
the where the the size of the input
would be the number of bases the number
of amino acids in the protein okay so so
these are all you know the sorts of
problems that uh you know people might
care about and you want to know sort of
what is the inherent difficulty of each
one so in a way that you know does not
depend on the details of are you using a
Mac or a PC but they're really just
ultimately depends on what are the laws
of physics that underlie your computer
and you know so so on the one hand that
means finding the fastest algorithm that
you can but on the other hand that also
means trying to rule out that you know
you can do any better than than some
limit right so trying to prove that that
some algorithm is the best one now that
is a lot harder
ya know it's a lot harder to prove a
negative than to you know to prove that
nothing can solve some problem than to
just find a way to solve it but often
what we can do is we can at least pass
past the blame to someone else okay in
the following sense that you know so so
let's say that you know the best
algorithm is n to the two point four and
let's say that you work on it and work
on it for you know months and months and
you just cannot get it down to end the
two point three right okay so you could
just give up you know admit that you're
just not very good okay but you
sometimes what you can do is you can say
well I can prove a theorem that says if
you could improve that the end to the
two point three then here are a thousand
other problems where you could also
improve over the best that anyone knows
okay so you know it's kind of it's not
my fault that I'm stuck it into the two
point four right and I and I can prove
that right it's a it's you know there's
a more fundamental difficulty so in
other word
we have this sort of set of problems
that are computer friendly right we can
state them precisely it's not like
autonomous driving where we're not quite
sure what we're doing there's there's a
set of india' bits and well we're what
we're discovering what you're
discovering is that there is structure
in the space of how hard these problems
are yes and you're trying to figure out
which problems sort of fit into
different classes so you become sort of
oh what's the word not not botanist but
you know someone who divides things into
species and things like that taxonomy
yeah yeah yeah I mean you know I yeah
and and I would say that like any other
kind of taxonomy right well you know
what you what you're really after are
sort of like the general laws general
principles right I mean like no one goes
into particle physics probably because
they just want to classify you know
every type of mezza you know or every
every type of baryon right you know but
that what you hope is that by
classifying things you know you will
notice patterns and then you'll notice
the deeper structure there if you're
interested in the kind of intellectual
topics we talk about here at mindscape
you might want to contemplate digging
deeper by checking out the great courses
Plus this is a streaming service that
brings you introductory college-level
courses taught by some of the best
teachers out there direct to whatever
device is most convenient for you the
topics covered are a great variety
eclair about history you could learn
about music even food and drink but of
course there's also a lot of science and
math courses being taught for example if
you're enjoying what we're talking about
on today's podcast you might want to
check out a course by Benjamin
Schumacher called the science of
information from language to black holes
the course covers information in a
variety of contexts from communication
to computers to DNA and genetics from
touring machines and computational
complexity all the way up to quantum
computers and the great thing is they're
offering my listeners a free trial of
unlimited access to the entire library
if you sign up for the great courses
plus today you can get that by going to
the great courses plus comm slash
scape that's t-h-e great courses PL us
calm / - Cape you get a free trial where
you can try out the entire library check
it out today yeah I mean I don't want to
zoom out of this too quickly because
it's it's something that to me is on the
one hand both perfectly obvious in
retrospect but also really kind of
profound the idea that the kinds of
questions we ask come along with a
different set of difficulties when it
comes to trying to solve oh yeah yeah
absolutely look you know the the theory
of computation as we understand it today
you could say it really started with
Alan Turing in the 1930s right writing
down a mathematical definition of what
we mean by a computer right you know he
had this concept of a Turing machine but
you know if you don't know what a Turing
machine is that's fine because you know
your iPhone you know or your you know
your your desk or Android or your you
know desktop PC right you know these are
all equivalent the Turing machines right
and in the sense that they're just were
not sufficiently powerful computers to
do the kinds of question in the specific
sense that they can all emulate one
another right
you know the merely some are faster some
are slower some will run out of memory a
little sooner than others will but you
know in principle and the limit where
you give them enough time and enough
memory they can all compute the same set
of functions yes right and so then you
know mathematicians you know magicians
you know spent decades just
understanding the boundary between what
is computable and what is not computable
right you know one of Touring's
great discoveries of course along with
the you know invention of the Turing
machine was the discovery that not
everything is computable okay in there
there are problems where you can just
prove that there is no algorithm to
solve them so they define infinite
complexity limit you can literally never
there's no number of steps that's
guaranteed to give you an answer
precisely so faithfully what's again
what's a question that falls into that
category
ah so that so the most famous example is
I give you a computer program now the
question it just does this program ever
stopped running right ok the the famous
halting problem
right and then that that may sound like
a kind of boring you know question for
like debugging some code but you know
but that question actually encodes sort
of a large fraction of all of
mathematics yeah okay because you know
we could write a program that just will
enumerate over all the zeros of the
Riemann zeta-function
and will halt only if there is one that
is not on the critical line right now
that is a program where to determine
whether that program halts or runs
forever
is equivalent to solving the Riemann
hypothesis right and you know you could
do the same for many many of the the
great unsolved problems of math so so
that's a you know a really profound
question maybe it shouldn't shock us too
much that there is no general algorithm
to solve it you know to sort of you know
like like um yeah math math does depend
on creativity right who would have
thought you know which which which
doesn't mean by the way that that human
mathematicians could never be beaten by
machines it just means that if they are
then the machines won't be perfect
either
yeah I mean this is a big big difficult
set of ideas it is it is what when you
say when we talk about the halting
problem I guess I have many questions
uh-huh but but yeah I mean you you you
use the word creativity what does that
mean can we it is easier it is much
easier to say what creativity is not
right if something can be done by a
completely mechanical algorithm that we
completely understand then maybe we
would say that there is no creativity
there yeah right so like a multiplying
of two integers you know for example
right it doesn't you know you might you
might do it choose to do it in a
creative way but it doesn't require
creativity but now we're skating on and
that has any in waters right where
gonna say that the others something
we're skating into Penrose I'm waters
where Roger Penrose is yeah yeah there's
something about the human brain that
can't be a computer because we are
creative and they're not yeah well so I
I don't I don't agree with them right
it's uh I mean I mean I mean I mean to
get to where Penrose goes you have to
take this further step of you know and
and sort of and furthermore you know I
am in some sense of perfect
mathematician right I can just see that
you know you know and and when it when I
make a statement like that or you know
maybe when I make it ex cathedra or
something like you know wearing my
official hat then I am never mistaken
right so we just slow down and unpack
that a little bit okay okay your words
what Penrose is trying to say yeah so so
so so he famously gave an argument which
is really an updating of an earlier
argument due to Lucas that said that uh
you know human creativity can never be
even a simulated by a machine right and
and and and and the the the argument
well you know we we could actually make
the argument in terms of the halting
problem as he sometimes does and they
say you know we you know there are
certain algorithmic problems that we
know just cannot be solved by computer
you know using using any amount of
resources but then he would say but in
these cases you know humans can just see
the the truth or falsehood of the
relevant statement you know maybe even
by by introducing new axioms if needed
yeah yeah it's that it's that second
part that I have problems with because
yeah I mean I get what I'm totally on
your side here but I yeah why he would
say that because I I have in my mind a
vision of staring at a computer screen
with a simple algorithm with a loop in
it yeah
and going oh yeah that's not gonna
terminate or oh yeah that is yep
and yes oh yeah why can't I put I mean
somehow if you prove that I can't do
that by a computer then it sounds like
you're proving that humans are better
right well the I think the main issue is
that when we talk about algorithms in
theoretical computer science we're
typically talking about algorithms that
always have to be correct right okay I
mean you know you can you can relax that
but but you know even then you know
you'll have some you know specific
condition like correct at least 99% of
the time on inputs that are chosen from
this distribution or something like that
right you have a formal criterion of you
know whether your algorithm succeeds or
fails and humans are not like that right
when we try to do science try to do math
you know there's no a priori guarantee
that we have to succeed right Andrew
Wiles when he started working on for Moz
last Ihram he had no guarantee of
success
Yeah right I mean you know like we we we
we can look back and we can count the
you know by confirmation bias we can
count the successes only but there are
lots of other big math problems that no
one has solved and for which we don't
even know whether they are solvable and
so if you as soon as you grant a machine
in the same Liberty that you know it can
try to you know learn from experience it
can make mistakes sometimes it can
sometimes just give up and say I don't
know then you know there is no longer
anything that sort of math or logic can
say against you know the machine doing
just as well as a human does or better
than the human does and if you want to
say that the computer is somehow not as
good I think you're sort of forced at
some point to retreat to internal
criteria like you could say well you
know the you know the computer is just
saying that it that it understands you
know why set theory is consistent but I
just really really feel it's consistence
yeah you know and I write yeah yeah but
at that point I think
you might as you know why even talk
about something as abstruse to set
theory you might as well just say but
you know when I taste the strawberry I
really taste the strawberry there are
people who said that full quality of
strawberry Ness right and the machine
could only be programmed to pretend that
you know and and that it just it just
reduces to the to the you know the usual
debate that everyone always goes in
circles with and it doesn't get anywhere
but but this is very good because I
think yeah point is that when we are
able to prove these theorems about what
computers can't do it's because we're
sort of restricting our notion of
computer to something very very specific
that it would be easy to jump out of
right if you if you give computers some
randomness some fallibilities some give
up ability then they then there's no
reason to think they can't be just as
good as us and vice versa well well it's
not so much that we're restricting the
computer as we're restricting what
counts the success okay right I mean I
mean you know we're saying that you you
know you really have to guarantee me
that you will get the right answer
you know you will halt and return the
right answer on all the inputs of this
type yeah for example and yeah and you
know as soon as you're you're allowed to
be heuristic well then a lot many more
possibilities open up but yes this is a
whole you know fascinating discussion
that you can have just about
computability but you know where I was
where I wanted to go was that when
people started building actual computers
you know in the 50s and 60s you know
they realized that well you know most of
what they really you know wanted to do
was computable in touring sense but
computable could mean computable but
taking an amount of time that grows like
2 to the 2 to the 2 to the 2 to the N
where n is the size of the input right
and now you know if n is right you know
more than one completely has right so so
so there so I think it was the actual
sort of digital computer revolution that
made people realize that that often the
much more important question than just
is something computable at all is you
know is it efficiently computable right
is it
beautiful in a way that avoids the sort
of brute force checking of
astronomically many possibilities and so
this is where we get into polynomial
versus exponential exactly exactly
yeah and I think you know that that is
sort of maybe you know the main insight
that you know touring and von Neumann
where we're kind of missing I mean well
you know you know maybe you know they
they they sort of understood it but you
know they I guess they had a lot of
other stuff on their plate so it was an
exciting time they could really think
yeah okay so give us more of a lay of
the land kind of explanation for what
these computability classes are there
are things that take exponentially long
things to take polynomial oh yeah what
else do we got
yes yes okay so uh okay so so you could
say you know the most basic thing you
could do is just try to classify
problems by you know how much time they
take how much memory they take so you
know what can be done with a polynomial
amount of time this is a class that we
call p4 Maui no meal you know every you
know I mean I mean you know physicists
have much better names for things right
but also no Big Bang black hole yes the
audience they should not get sanguine
because that's the only label this could
even make sense and what's to come
there's there's everything you can do
with a polynomial amount of space or
memory that's called P space that's
pretty intuitive isn't it okay great and
and and and and that's a potentially
larger class okay because you know you
could use the same memory over and over
but for an exponential amount of time
right
so you could say polynomial time is
contained in polynomial space which is
contained in exponential time okay and
and and the reason you know polynomial
space is contained in exponential time
is that well if I have let say n bits of
memory then my computer can pass through
it most two to the N power possible
states before either it halts or else
that gets into an infinite
right an infinite recurrence right so uh
so you know you can relate time and
space to each other in that kind of way
now you know already here we encounter
some you know enorm some of the most
enormous open problems in mathematics so
for example is polynomial time equal to
polynomial space
no one knows we we we expect that the
answer is no but no one has proven that
so sorry let's let's yeah let that go by
too quickly so you say okay all right
contained in but you didn't yeah you
didn't mean that it's properly we're not
sure whether it's that's right exactly
exactly everything you can do in
polynomial time you can also do in
polynomial memory and that's because you
know each you know at least if I have
like a serial computer each time step is
you know accessing at most one memory
location right the way after key time I
can I you know access the most key
memory but uh but but we don't know
whether everything you can do in
polynomial memory can also be done in
polynomial time you know we would we
would we would we would expect no
because that would if the answer were
yes that would mean that for example
there was just some super duper
algorithm to play chess perfectly or go
or any other game okay you know not not
merely as well as let's say alphago
plays it but you know to play it
perfectly okay good and fill in the
details there you mean because we could
save it enough memory well because you
know it is known that you could
perfectly play any of these you know
games like two player games of perfect
information using a small amount of
memory because all you need to do is
evaluate what's called the game tree the
game tree is the thing that says you
know is there a move I can make such
that for every move that the opponent
makes there is a move I can make and so
on such that I win right and that's a
tree where you can basically just
traverse that tree you know it's an
exponentially large tree but you can
reuse the same memory over and over
right so playing games
as a problem you can do in small memory
now if P were equal to P space that
would mean that perfectly playing all
these games would also be a problem that
you could solve in a small amount of
time yeah okay okay and that would be
amazing right so okay and then you know
is pspace equal to exponential time so
everything that you can do in
exponential time can you also do it with
small memory again no one knows we
expect that the answer is no no one has
proven it okay now I don't want to give
the impression that we're complete it
you know ignoramus okay so you know as
one example we do know that exponential
time is bigger than polynomial time okay
that we know okay okay so you can prove
that more time it when you've got more
time then you can solve more problems
that you couldn't solve with less time
when you've got likewise when you've got
more memory you can solve more problems
that you couldn't solve with less memory
okay but when you're comparing different
resources like time against space then
it becomes very hard so just to
translate that you're saying that we
know there are problems that cannot be
solved in polynomial time but can be as
an exponential time and likewise for
spectra cisely yes and even even more
fine-grain than that like we know that
there are problems that can be solved in
n to the two point four time that cannot
be solved in n to the two point three
time for example let me pause for a
second to talk about grammarly this is
an app that can help you improve as a
writer it's not something very simple
that just corrects your spelling
mistakes grammarly is a digital writing
assistant that actually improves your
style I personally found it very useful
because not only does it say well you
made a grammatical mistake here
it offers suggestions for vocabulary
improvements or the tone of what you're
writing or even ways to make your
writing more vivid grammerly works
across a variety of different apps
whether you're typing a document in Word
or whether you're on Twitter or Gmail or
whatever grammarly can step in and offer
extremely useful advice to raise your
writing to the next level with grammarly
premium you can set goals you can get
overall writing score vocabulary
suggestions concision checks and more
and right now you can get 20% off
grammarly premium if you go to sign up
at grammarly calm mindscape that's a
special offer for mindscape listeners
20% off at grammarly calm slash mind
scape GRA MMA r ly dot-com / mindscape
it is an interesting feature of this
field that I'm not going to give you a
hard time for not having proven anything
yet that's okay
everything everything the things that we
most want but but it is there is this
thing that comes up over and over again
where here's something we haven't proven
yet but every person has the same
opinion about what the answer is
eventually going to be because it would
lead to this very very strange thing if
it turned out not to be true
how reliable is that sort of quasi
argument in your mind well I mean I mean
I think that we need to be prepared for
the possibility of surprises I mean you
know I would I would say that there
already have been surprises right there
have been cases where you know people
thought that to complexity classes were
different that then turned out to be the
same I would say that none of those
would were nearly as surprising as let's
say P equals P space would be would be
right but you know but but you know
there were things that that you know I
mean I mean look if there were no
surprises then you know you know well
you could say well why even do it right
you know so yes there there have been
surprises but well you know what what I
I think that the right way to think
about it is that you know even though
this is pure math you know the way that
we approach it has some elements of
empirical science also right so I mean I
mean I mean physicists right you know
don't prove that you know there's no
superluminal signaling right they don't
prove that you know quantum mechanics is
correct right I mean these are taken as
you know very well-supported assumptions
relative to our present state of
knowledge let's say yeah right or you
know and and and then you
much more fine-grain things than that
like that there's you know CPT symmetry
and that there you know and on and on
right and you know and you could have
sort of a hierarchy of surprising this
right if you could send you know if
let's say the Opera experiment had been
correct and you know you could really
send neutrinos faster than light well
then you know that is like that is sort
of at the top of the hierarchy of
surprising this right and there are you
know many other things that could happen
in physics that are you know you know
you know not not not quite as surprising
as that you know a you know a new
particle at the LHC but still you know
you would yeah you would take right yeah
it would still be you know and it would
still overturn something that had been
previously believed it's no I think that
it's amazing to me how many people bring
up those those damn superluminal
neutrinos as something that everyone's
had something you guys almost believe
that for a while well no I mean I mean
what the the physicist oh I knew I mean
not none of them you know thought it was
very likely that it was correct
we had priors were good billions so
that's exactly exactly and and and and I
would say it's exactly the same with us
right we were just trying to be Bayesian
x' and have priors right on things and
you know I would I would you know you
know you you you can say like if to
complexity classes let's say you know if
they have been enormous li studied for
like sixty years and you know again and
again people did things that like if
they had turned out slightly differently
than these two classes would have been
equal and yet every single time you know
it just sort of miraculously avoids you
know whatever theorem they proved just
sort of miraculously avoids the thing
that would that would make those classes
equal then you know you start to suspect
that well maybe there's a deep reason
why they're different do you begin to
anthropomorphize your complexity classes
as you learn more and more about them do
you like say like they don't want this
to how absolutely oh absolutely I mean
you know you know I mean know that you
know this is the thing like like like
each one has a personality you know
they're they're like they're like
they're like comic-book superheroes
right each one has a different set of
powers right you know and like you know
some sometimes you know some are just
clearly better you know more powerful
than others
other times you get two classes with
just you know bizarrely incomparable
powers right and so then you try to
compare them to each other but it's just
kind of like asking you know like like
like I don't know um you know it's like
one of these internet memes in a fight
like Godzilla or Batman no sorry just
they're from different universes right
but yeah but but so so you know the the
sort of less you know obvious may be
slightly less obvious thing you you you
you you can do but it turns out to be
absolutely central importance is you
define complexity classes in terms of
what is provable okay you're like what
has a short proof right and and this
this is what weeds do I would say the
next you know most famous complexity
class along with P which is called NP
hmm okay now uh NP doesn't stand for not
polynomial C okay stands for it stands
for non-deterministic polynomial but
don't worry about what that means okay
it's you know I can I can say what it
means in plain language okay a problem
is in NP if whenever the answer to it is
yes meaning like yes there is a solution
then someone can show you the solution
and you could check the solution using a
polynomial time algorithm hmm okay so so
let me give an example like a jigsaw
puzzle okay you know like a especially
if there's no picture on the jigsaw
puzzle okay it could be you know it
could take quite a while to do one right
but once it's done and you know you've
made some neat square well then you know
you can anyone who doesn't believe that
you did it you just show them that you
did it
right similarly you know finding the
prime factors of a gigantic number right
this is a you know well well you know
for better or worse most of the
encryption that we use on the Internet
is based on the belief that this problem
is hard yeah you know this and a few
closely related problems that finding
the prime factors of a gigantic number
is a hard problem but if you did find
the factors then well you know you you
might not want to multiply them but your
computer could very easily multiply them
and check that those factors you know
we're the correct ones
likewise with a Sudoku puzzle
likewise you know with with optimization
problems I mean it might hard it might
be hard to prove that you found the best
solution but you know if you just want
to convince let's say your your
consultant you know you want to convince
your client that you found the solution
that will only cost them this much money
right well you just show them your
solution okay so so these are all
examples of NP problems and the way
things fit together is that P is
contained in NP which is contained in P
space by the way I make it clear that
everyone knows yeah absolutely
absolutely the picture that we have you
know there's like this big space of
problems and we draw some kind of Venn
diagram of the these complexity classes
but you don't need to be nested right
like to complexity classes can have some
intersection but some non intersection
also and a third one might intersect
with some of them but not others right
is that fair absolutely don't all of
these things happen okay yes
right so I mean I mean I mean some of
them do fit in in a linear order you
know as I was saying before we're
probably not well right some of some of
them do fit that way like P is contained
in NP is contained in P space yeah is
contained in X meaning exponential time
and you know we believe that each one is
strictly more powerful than the last but
all we know so far is that X is larger
than P
okay so yeah which means that either P
is different from NP or NP is different
from P space or P space is different
from X right at least one of those three
has to be true we think all three of
them but we only know that at least one
is true and you man
now the most yeah you mentioned about
factoring that you believe it's hard but
you didn't say that we know it's hard
that's right that's right so right so
now you know we can go in and now you
know I mean I mean firfer in fact we
don't know that any NP problem is hard
right I mean this is the you know this
has been the situation for the last half
century that uh you know we we you know
famously we cannot prove that p is not
equal to NP so sorry
and yeah NP problems are those that we
can easily check the answers to and
you're exactly exactly there are
problems that are hard to solve but easy
to check but we can't exactly cannot
prove it yet exactly exactly
that is if you fer ya if listeners have
heard of the famous P versus NP question
that is that question and and and now
now factoring is an NP problem but you
know but factoring we think is a very
special problem okay so it could be that
someone just discovers a fast algorithm
for factoring you know and then you know
that would that would break most of the
security of electronic commerce but it
wouldn't necessarily mean that P would
equal NP right yeah cuz maybe they just
solve that one special problem okay
now the the surprising part the big
surprise to people in the early 1970s
was that most of the hard problems in NP
are not like that most of them have an
amazing property of universality
property that we call NP completeness
okay and what NP completeness means is
that you show that your one specific
problem has the property that if anyone
could solve it in polynomial time then P
would equal NP then
you could solve every NP problem in
polynomial thought so this goes back to
the thing that you mentioned before
where you just relate to the hardness of
problems to each other even exactly you
might not know what the hardness of any
of them are but yes I do they're equally
hard you know it's all the same yeah so
so so wait so you know and this is
exactly what I was talking about before
about you know you know you you may
start out as a taxon amidst but
ultimately you want to discover
something deeper right and what you
discover is that you know there is this
you know this huge class of easy
problems you know the P problems then
you know then then there's this huge
metropolis of hardness you like these
and these np-complete problems right uh
you know which includes just literally
thousands of the problems that sort of
engineers and scientists you know we
care about you know airline scheduling
traveling salesperson problem you know
um just about any kind of combinatorial
optimization problem that you know you
could imagine involving you know a whole
bunch of variables a whole bunch of
constraints you know certain problems
like that will will be np-complete
unless they have good reasons not to be
is this one of those ones where they
packing luggage into your trunk is one
of them yep fitting fitting luggage into
the trunk of your car that might be one
that many people have experience with
there's that there's a beauty there's a
beautiful paper from a decade ago that
proves that Super Mario is np-complete
yes you have to create these crazy
levels with like these weird patterns of
these Cooper's that you stomp on you
know that encode the logic problem but
you you can you can do that so basically
you get the Lugg yam your trunk is a
good is a good reminder because even
though we say np-complete means
SuperDuper hard people haven't put
luggage in their trunk what we mean is
they have as their trunks have if you
imagine large and larger trunks and more
and more luggage it just become not very
unwieldy very quickly that's right
that's right what it what it means is
if I wanted to I could you know give you
a very very hard time figuring out how
to fit some luggage into your trunk like
I could even in principle I could design
some you know millions of boxes of
different dimensions you know that would
have the property that you can fit you
know these boxes into your trunk and
have it closed if and only if there is a
proof of the Riemann hypothesis of it
most a certain X okay or or or or for
example that that in order to fit them
in your trunk you would have to break
some cryptographic code I could also do
that but if someone's okay we'll wait to
put them in your trunk he would be
easily enough to be able to say yep that
worked it was easy to check yep
exactly exactly yes so so so so there's
these np-complete problems you know and
it's sort of a priori it didn't have to
be that way but you know this is this is
a substantive discovery right that you
know these most of these hard and P
problems are actually all equivalent to
one another yeah in the sense that a
fast algorithm for any one of them
implies a fast algorithm for all the
rest and then there are a few outliers
right factoring is one of the weird ones
okay that might be sort of somewhere in
between P and NP complete and some
no-man's land
besides the anthropomorphize ation and
the personalities it does thinking about
yeah of tend to turn you into a
mathematical Platonism mathematical
reality out there because of all the
structure that you wouldn't have
imagined existing before finding it yeah
I mean I mean I I feel like probably
every mathematician we a wall they're
actually doing their work is in practice
a plate in this right you know they
might claim later that they're not one
right but I mean to do math is to you
know you know a push back against
something that can tell you that you
were wrong right it's not just you know
a thing that you were making up right it
is the thing that has constraints that
are external to you and in that way you
know you know if it is like empirical
science well
yeah you made that point before yeah
it's really interesting because you I
think you've made the point like in
comments on my blog that this kind of
discovery I will mention in the
introduction that you are a world-famous
blogger and stuff like that but ah you
that the kinds of things we learn about
the real world by these purely
mathematical discoveries are you know at
least rubbing shoulders with the kinds
of things we learn about the real world
by doing empirical science like the
universe we have been expanding or
contracting and we had to go out and
look at it to find out which way it was
but it's really really hard to put boxes
into your trunk in the most efficient
way and you want to sort of say that one
of those is comparable to the other in
terms of important insights about the
universe yeah III I mean you know it's
funny because you know I've you know I I
am often in conversations with my many
many physicists friends where you know
we are ribbing each other and you know
when they will point out that oh you
know I'm just a plate inist and some
abstract whoa and while they're dealing
with the real world and then you know if
these are theoretical physicists I can
reply that I've actually I'm an author
on more experimental papers than they
are you know yeah yeah but you know I
mean I mean I mean look I mean you know
even in physics right you know you you
are a theoretical physicist and
cosmologist right you know you are not
you know to on a typical day out at the
observatory
you know peering through a lens right
you are thinking you are you know
thinking hard about things that we
already know and trying to deduce the
consequences of those things or trying
to build models that explain something
and that's also what we do in math and
in theoretical computer science ya know
I just want to give you guys to put into
your work yeah yeah yeah yeah sure but
no I I have described my position as not
so much plate inist but an anti anti
platanus okay
because you know look look I mean I mean
I mean Plato wrote
all kinds of you know really weird
trippy stuff right and I you know I
don't want to like give him a blank
check that I agree with whatever he said
you know I haven't even read enough of
play-doh to know you know if I if I
agree with everything he said radio and
then it sounds quasi-mystical and weird
to be talking about this world of you
know perfect triangles and you know
perfect squares or whatever right you
know I don't I don't know if it has a
metaphysical existence but I will say
this that you know if we ever encounter
an extraterrestrial civilization and you
know we are able to communicate with
them I think that they will agree with
us about the Pythagorean theorem right I
think that they will you know have
discovered much of the same math as we
will as we have discovered because I
think that it is not just an arbitrary
cultural creation I mean it has cultural
aspects but you know it is sort of
constrained by you know the well by by
logic by by truth well yeah okay I mean
let me push back a little bit on that in
my role as devil's advocate and on the
part yes the Pythagorean theorem is true
in Euclidean geometry so it's it's a
conditional statement that says if you
accept the following set of axioms then
you prove the Pythagorean theorem and
and every statement in math is like that
if the axioms are then the conclusions
follow but so one could say we will
never learn anything exclusively about
the actual world that way because we
don't know what axioms are true yeah I
mean you know they're there okay so so
so there are really two questions right
won't you know what one is
you know which we could call the easy
question you know if we can agree on the
same axioms with the aliens will we
agree about the consequences of those
axioms right right and and I I hope most
people would agree that the answer is
yes yes yeah you know well we'll agree
about what are the laws of logic or sort
of what are the rules of inference that
we can use to validly draw conclusions
from axioms right but then there's sort
of a broader question maybe a harder
question you know will we and the aliens
have thought of the same axioms right
we'll or will we have thought of about
similar mathematical objects such as
Euclidean space you know the space where
the Pythagorean theorem holds or such as
the positive integers right and I think
you know that okay so there certainly
are some you know mathematical objects
that you know we have invented that
probably the aliens will not will not
have invented chess would be an example
of such an object you know maybe like
you know particular cryptographic codes
that we happen to use like a EES you
know I doubt the aliens will have that
but you know I'd be willing to wager a
lot that the aliens will have a concept
of integers that they will have a
concept of Euclidean space you know and
even more than that they will have a
concept of complex numbers you know and
and and and things of that kind right
there are certain things that are just
really really fundamental to the
mathematical universe where even if you
started out in a different direction you
would eventually have to reinvent those
concepts because they're so ubiquitous
if I were really being the devil's
advocate I would say that maybe the
reason why certain sets of axioms seem
so natural to us is because not of math
but because of physics of the particular
way the physical world around us has
arranged itself to make certain things
more natural for us to describe it yeah
well okay well well then it becomes an
even more interesting question right
well I could say yeah okay so you know I
I was imagining talking to aliens who
live in the same universe as we do even
though they had absolutely separate of
evolutionary history but now we could
also imagine some aliens in a pair you
know in some parallel universe with
completely different laws of physics
right right maybe you know it's not even
quantum mechanics maybe they don't even
have a space-time even approximately I
don't know maybe they're all just
sitting on top of each other or
something but yeah I mean I mean one
thing that we can say is that you know
we can imagine many ways that the laws
of
could have been different but where you
know we would have invented much the
same math in order to think about it
yeah right so I mean I mean you know we
and and in fact it all it has happened
again and again in the history of math
and physics that you know mathematicians
have invented a certain concept well in
advance of that concept being needed by
physics sure right they had their own
reasons for inventing it you know that
were not in any direct way motivated by
physics but then they just turned out to
be you know very handy you know when
when when when physics had reached a
certain point and I think you know if
you look at examples like that you know
you could say maybe that is just because
these concepts are so fundamental that
you know sort of sort of any laws of
physics if you go deep enough into them
you want to understand them deeply
enough you know you might be tempted to
reinvent those concepts like for example
concepts of symmetry groups would be an
example yeah I think that this is a
rabbit hole we could profitably dig even
deeper but I do want to switch topics on
to your opinion of what I've heard on
the internet which is that once we build
quantum computers all these hard
problems will become suddenly easy ah ok
yes oh so this this actually feeds
beautifully into the discussion that we
were having earlier about you know could
could there be like different classes of
problems with different incomparable
powers right now a perfect now a perfect
example of that is provided by quantum
computers ok so a you know the once we
ask sort of what is efficiently
computable right what is computable in
polynomial time
you know you might worry that the answer
to that might depend somewhat on physics
right and you know and actually you know
apparently it was asking that question
that sort of led David Deutsch
to the idea of quantum computing in the
first place and there
nineteen eighty so the way it could
eventually depend on physics is because
what it means to do a computation
depends on what kind of physical things
you're pushing around precisely
precisely now now Touring's definition
of computability in the 1930s had this
sort of amazing invariance to the
details of physics like it just it
doesn't care whether the universe is
classical or quantum or you know how
many spatial dimensions there are right
you just get the same notion of
computability okay but once we ask about
efficient computability polynomial time
computability well then you know it's
still very very insensitive to a lot of
the details of physics you know and
that's that's sort of why we like this
notion you know that it gives you a nice
elegant theory doesn't depend on you
know your specific model of computer but
the really cool thing that emerged in
the 80s and 90s is that well changing
the laws of physics from classical to
quantum that does seem to be enough to
enlarge what is computable in polynomial
time okay once again this shouldn't
surprise you at this point no one can
know one has proven that right okay we
think so okay so so so the way that you
know to say this and complexity language
is that there is a class of all the
problems that are solvable in polynomial
time
using a quantum computer which you know
we could get into exactly what that
means but you know it's a computer that
could have not just bits in its memory
but quantum bits what we call qubits
bits that can be in superposition states
and that can even be entangled with each
other right and so the sort of key
property here is that if I have let's
say a thousand cubits thousand quantum
bits then just to describe their state I
need a list of two to the one thousand
complex numbers okay I need an what
quantum mechanical amplitude for every
possible configuration of all of these
bits so we're we're you know we're we're
talking about enormous lis
larger objects here right and and so
that at least opens up the potential
that we could compute more things in
polynomial time you know it will take
work to see whether that potential was
realized but we can define a class of
problems that is called
bqp bounded error quantum polynomial
time this was defined in 93 by mesh
maserati who was my advisor at berkeley
and his student then Ethan Bernstein and
they basically just defined it as a
quantum mechanical generalization of P
so it's like what you can do in
polynomial time with a quantum computer
the B for a bounded error that's just
saying that well the you know the
computer doesn't always have to output a
right answer it's just for every input
you know the you should have let's say
at least a 90% chance of getting the
right answer because the and you know
and we're ember we're we're happy with
that because if you don't like ninety
percent well then just repeat the
computation all bunch of times and take
the majority vote among the answers yeah
right so so so that's B Q P now it's you
know it it was it's it's pretty easy to
show that bqp contains classical P or in
other words a quantum computer can
always efficiently simulate a classical
computer that makes it right the way I
like to describe that it's like you
could use the Space Shuttle to taxi
around the parking lot I mean it
wouldn't be very smart wouldn't be you
know very useful but you could do it
right the interesting question is you
know is bqp larger than P there is are
there things that you could solve in
polynomial time with a quantum computer
but you can't solve in polynomial time
with a classical computer that would
even take exponential time for a
classical computer right okay so and you
know we don't know the answer I mean the
way I mean richard fineman talked about
this in the early 80s you know he
suggested the problem well what about
the problem
stimulating quantum mechanics itself
right and you know and and and and that
is one of our best candidates to this
day for what a quantum computer will be
useful for you know if and when we can
really make make it practical okay but
you know maybe some people would like a
less thought illogical example so you
know what a quantum computer could do or
sort of an example that is not itself
about quantum mechanics so that came by
you know and now super famous discovery
in 1994 and this was when Peter shor
discovered Shor's algorithm for
factoring okay so what sure discovered
was that the problem of factoring huge
numbers the one that we talked about
before right the one that most modern
encryption is is based upon and then you
know that's an NP problem but it's kind
of special we don't know whether it's in
P or not or not sure showed that the
factoring problem is in BQ p okay
so we showed that if you could build a
quantum computer then you could factor
an N digit number using a number of
elementary operations that only scales
like N squared roughly right okay so
that means that excuse me whereas the
classical belief the best-known
classical algorithm takes time that
grows like exponentially and roughly the
cube root of n okay okay it's something
it's something fancy called the number
field sieve exponential even though the
Exponential's yeah yeah well count that
as exponential and you know the I am
sure that the NS a you know cares
enormous ly about you know the exact
three factors and that exponential and
so forth but yeah well but we don't work
out that as exponential yeah yeah but we
don't know that there isn't a better one
classically that's the issue that's
right that's we absolutely do not know
that and you know and and in fact we
don't know you know it could it could be
for all we know today that P equals bqp
right in other words maybe everything
that a quantum computer can efficiently
saw
could also be efficiently solved by a
classical computer right right so you
know what sure showed you know again
it's sort of you know we're waiting are
different you know uh domains of
ignorance right he said you know if you
wanted a general way to simulate quantum
mechanics with a classical computer then
you would also have to invent a fast
classical algorithm for factoring yeah
and it is true we I think we do know
that there are problems for which there
is a quantum algorithm that is provably
faster than any classical algorithm but
not in an entirely different complexity
class is that is that right yes right so
this is okay good good now now we're
getting to something that is you know
when I teach my undergraduate class this
is always you know one of the the more
subtle points to but I'm glad you're
asking about it there is a thing called
the black box model okay where it's sort
of a different game a different domain
where you just ask the question suppose
that I have a black box that you know
just evaluate some function for free
right and now I you know like like maybe
it's a subroutine or I don't know its
inner-workings for example okay and and
now I just ask how many questions do I
need to ask to this black box in order
to learn something that I want okay so
you know as an example like I I love you
know playing a game you know playing the
game with my seven-year-old daughter
where you know she shall think of a
number from you know one to a hundred
and you know and then I say you know is
it bigger smaller than 50 is it bigger
smaller than 75 so you know and with
with seven questions you can find a
number right so she would then be the
you know a black box and we could say
that the query complexity of this
problem is like 7 queries right but now
you know you could you could ask and
people have asked well what changes if I
could somehow ask my daughter many
questions in quantum superposition and
get back a superposition of answers
anyone can do it what Y is going to be
you
what if anyone I think you're the best
bet okay alright alright anyway you know
in this model of of query complexity
here we really do have proven advantages
of quantum computers over classical ones
and some of these advantages are
exponential some of them are even more
than exponential in the way like there
are problems that involving n bits of
input where it takes a square root of it
about square root of n queries to solve
them classically and they can be solved
with only one query with a quantum
computer hmm okay literally one that
that's by the way a paper that uh my
colleague Andres and by Yunus and I
wrote five years ago and we also proved
that that gap is the largest possible
one between classical and quantum ok
yeah ok but yeah yeah but so in this mop
you know in the setting of query
complexity we do know how to prove that
quantum computers are are strictly
better than classical ones for some
problem but now you could say you know
in the real world you know so so so so
so query complexity is like a very very
useful playground for sort of figuring
out what might be true sort of like if
you can't even get a separation inquiry
complexity then probably you have no
chance to get a separation in the real
world right between one type of computer
and another type okay but you know
ultimately you do want you know you do
want an advantage of quantum computers
that will persist even in the real world
where where you don't have these magic
boxes for answering questions right so
you know I've I often explain it to
physicist by saying you know query
complexity is our perturbation theory
like you know it is it is it is it is
this that it is the street light to look
for your keys under yeah right where you
can actually answer the questions but
okay so so in this sort of quote-unquote
real world there you know what we know
is that P is contained in B Q P meaning
everything a classical computer can do
so can a quantum computer
yeutter we also know that bqp is
contained in P space which means
anything that you can do in polynomial
time with a quantum computer you can
also do in polynomial space with a
classical computer hmm okay so that
means that means several things that
means that you know in in terms of like
running time in the real world quantum
computers could it most give you an
exponential advantage over classical
ones right so they're not going to solve
the halting problem okay they're not
gonna solve anything that is literally
uncomputable for a classical computer
but they could solve certain things up
to exponentially faster today and you
know it also means that you know we have
a very good excuse for why we cannot
prove today that quantum computers are
are better than classical computers in
the real world there and the reason is
if you wanted to prove that p is not
equal to b QP well then you would also
have to prove that p is not equal to p
space that's the famous unsolved problem
that's like as big a problem is P versus
NP yep right except you make money for
solving it yeah well yeah they're right
right that it happens not to have a
million-dollar prize but you know you
know like oh you know what I say about
this by the way that you know so so
there were these from people who don't
know there are these seven million
dollar clay challenge problems you know
the first one is P versus NP and then
there's a Riemann hypothesis there's the
Pangkor a conjecture which was solved by
Perelman although he refused the prize
iiiiii i wouldn't have done that okay
yeah and there are four other problems
you know I like to say that P versus NP
is just clearly the most important of
the seven right and you know and and I
have several reasons for that one of
them is that well if P you know if you
could prove that P were equal to NP and
furthermore your algorithm was actually
efficient in practice so now like n to
the one salicin but you know let's say N
squared or something like that well then
yeah you could not only collect a
million dollars for solving that
but you could also solve the other six
problems because you would just program
your computer to say you know is there a
proof of you know at most a million
characters you know written in some
formal language that a computer can
check right right and because you know
computer can easily check the proof that
means that if it's there then if P
equals NP the computer can also easily
find the proof okay but not only that I
mean forget about these measly million
dollars right
you know if P equals NP well I mean you
know you could start by stealing two
hundred billion dollars worth of Bitcoin
and I guess then I guess then decide
what to do next in your quest for world
domination okay but I think you know
it's important because it really is
driving home the reason why when
mathematicians say things like even
though we haven't proven that P is
different from NP we're all foods yeah
true because NP R is this collection of
problems some of which seem so hard that
if you show that they were really easy
you'd be axiom 't izing all sorts of
things that we think are just
preposterous ly difficult exactly so yes
so so I mean I mean some people you know
they may have an intuition that well you
know like like when I run across
np-complete problems in my application
domain which might be some you know
machine learning some AI optimization oh
you know they tend not to be so hard I
just wanted some heuristic algorithm and
it does perfectly well so you know so
well you know what makes you so sure
that P is different from NP and you know
and my response tends to be well you
know well why haven't you made billions
of dollars from mining Bitcoin yeah
right I mean you know you could say you
know since since 2008 that's been the
easiest answer right I mean you know you
I mean I mean yes if you only try to
solve easy instances of your problem
then they will be easy but you know the
the point of a problem being np-complete
is that you can encode these enormities
into it like finding a proof of the
Riemann hypothesis like you know mining
billions of dollars of Bitcoin and you
know and and and and and so forth you
know anything
for which an answer could be easily
checked or you know another example
would be compress Wikipedia you know
into like the bet you know the best come
like come you know the smallest file you
can write where it could then be easily
decompressed okay that's another example
of an NP problem where you know in order
to solve that problem it is you know at
least a plausible speculation that the
computer would have to sort of
understand human knowledge in a very
very deep way right and solve a lot of
the problems of artificial intelligence
but you know again if B equals NP it
would just you know you would just type
it with a few keystrokes you would do
that and likewise this is why we our
intuition tells us that even quantum
computers are not going to be able to
solve np-complete problems exactly yes
or now so we're good so now we come to
you know a a wonderful example of two
complexity classes two models of
computation that we really do think are
incomparable and those are or that as
far as we know are incomparable and
those are NP and bqp okay so you know
the easily checkable problems and the
problems that are easily solvable by a
quantum computer right now you know the
the in some sense the biggest mistake
that popular writers make when they
write about quantum computers you know
and we uh you know and then this has
been true for like 25 years by now okay
is that they sort of they conflate NP
with bqp y right
they write as if a quantum computer
would just be a magical machine for
solving NP problems they say well look a
quantum computer just has to try each
possible answer in a different parallel
universe you know a different branch of
the wavefunction then the you know and
and in something you know it is actually
true that a quantum computer can do that
yeah that's not even a hard thing to do
to program your quantum computer to
create a superposition over every
possible answer the hard part is reading
out the answer that you want okay so you
know if I just you know
I mean you know this Shawn but you know
for the benefit of our listeners right
if I just create an equal superposition
over every possible answer to some you
know super hard problem like you know uh
all possible keys for you know breaking
a cryptographic code let's say and and
then I just measure it not having done
anything else the rules of quantum
mechanics tell me that what I will see
will just be a random a random answer
yeah well if I just wanted a random key
I could have pick one myself with a lot
less trouble right I didn't need to
build a quantum computer for that okay
so you know it's but you know then you
know that that makes it sounds like then
maybe quantum computers are not really
useful for anything at all you know if
all they can do is pick random answers
but now it you know it is it is a little
more than that that they can do and the
reason why we say why they can do more
is that the quantum rules of probability
are different from the classical rules
of probability okay so in in quantum
mechanics each possible configuration
that your system could be and gets
assigned this number called an amplitude
right which is very closely related to
you know the probability that you see
the system and in that configuration
when you look at it but it's not a
probability so unlike probabilities
amplitudes can be negative they can even
be complex numbers okay and in some
sense the central trick in quantum
computing sort of the trick you know
behind every single quantum algorithm is
this that you are trying to choreograph
a pattern of interference of these
amplitudes okay where for each wrong
answer what you would like is for the
amplitude of that wrong answer to be a
sum of many contributions but
potentially but some of those
contributions should have positive
amplitude and some should have negative
amplitude or you know they should point
in every which way in the complex plane
and so they mostly just cancel each
other out
whereas for the right answer the answer
that you do want to see you would like
all of the contributions to its
amplitude to be pointing the same way or
mostly the same way okay so you would
like constructive interference like a
recipe for the am put for the amplitude
of the right answer if you can arrange
that then when you measure the right
answer will be seen with high
probability and of course if it's not
seen you can just try again until it is
right but you're trying to exploit
interference to boost the probability of
seeing the right answer to way way more
than it would have been with any
similarly efficient classical algorithm
yeah now you know the tricky parts here
or that way you know you've got to do
all of this despite not knowing yourself
which answer is the right one in advance
right you know if you knew that then
there would kind of be no point right so
you know you need to sort of arrange
this interference pattern where you know
for some mathematical reason that it's
going to concentrate the amplitude on
the right answer even though you don't
know yet which one that is right and
you've got to do it fast you've got to
do it you know much faster than just a
classical brute-force method could have
found that same answer or else you know
the quantum computer is not winning
right so you know it was you know it is
a really bizarre hammer that nature
gives us for sort of extending
computation you know beyond what what
throwing knew about right and it is sort
of it is a happy miracle that we can
occasionally find some nails for that
hammer to hit okay yeah you know uh
factoring was a very famous example of
such a nail right you know but now it is
very important for people to understand
that you design his fast quantum
algorithm for factoring Peter shor
really had to exploit some very special
structure in the factoring problem yeah
stuff that comes from you know from
group theory from number theory from the
Fourier transform you know it's just a
beautiful set of ideas that goes into it
but it is not something as simple as
just I try every possible divisor and it
friend you know parallel universe you
know if we're that simple you wouldn't
have needed Peter Stewart to think of it
okay and it is not as far as we know it
is not something that extends generalize
this to the np-complete problems right
it is you know I said before that
factoring is not believed to be and be
complete right right it has a lot of
very very special structure I mean just
one one simple example is you know if I
gave you a you know some boxes to fit
into your trunk a priori they might not
fit at all or there might be only one
way to fit them or there might be a
thousand ways to fit them right you
don't know but if I give you some huge
composite number then no matter how hard
it is to factor you know in advance that
it has one and only one prime
factorization Yeah right because you
could prove that 300 BC right so so so
factoring is special in a whole bunch of
ways and you know it's specialness on
the one hand is what makes it so useful
for cryptography right you use the
structure of factoring to do all the
beautiful things that enable modern
cryptography but the the other side of
the coin is that that structure is what
sure was able to exploit in order to
sort of choreograph this interference
pattern with a quantum computer that
reveals the factors of your number but
this does sound off a little
deflationary in the sense that I'm sure
you'll correct this but it sounds like
it's factoring we sort of lucked into it
in the sense that it is a hard problem
but one that quantum computers are very
good at typical exponentially hard
problems will still be exponentially
hard on a quantum computer is that a
safe thing to say that is what we think
yeah that is what we think and this is
by the way this is something that you
know I have been you know I've been
trying to exam you know it is not
controversial
by the way within the field and I've
been trying to explain it to you know
people for fifteen or twenty years it
used to be the tagline of my blog
because I found myself just explaining
the same thing to journalists like week
after week
you're weak like no we do not expect the
quantum computers will just
exponentially speed-up everything you
know it depends on the structure of your
problem and you know because you know
this is this is often not what people
want to hear but you know I feel like we
should be telling the truth like you
know now Cass will do it now that you're
on mindscape I think that everyone will
know I mean you know I and you know III
love you know having a having a forum
that is that is though devoting okay but
no no I should say that for even for in
for np-complete problems we don't expect
an exponential speed-up from a quantum
computer you know like once again we
can't prove that you know which is no
great surprise you know we can't even
prove that you know that fee is
different from n right we can't if we
can't even prove that classical
computers can't solve these problems
quickly yeah I mean far less can we
prove that quantum computers can't do it
but what we what we generally think is
that quantum computers would give you
more modest speed ups for these problems
okay so after Shor's algorithm may be
the second most famous quantum algorithm
is called Grover's algorithm okay it was
discovered just shortly afterward
growver by the way was like like worked
down the hall from Peter shor then at
Bell Labs so you know these ideas where
we're in the air then and I actually
started in the field doing a summer
internship with Grover okay but what he
discovered was that there is a quantum
algorithm that can search a list any pot
like list of n possibilities in only
about the square root of n steps okay
we're you know classically if I just
told you here are n boxes and inside one
of them is a golden nugget well you know
you're gonna on average you're gonna
have to open about n over two of the box
until you find that nugget right there's
just you know I've just sort of bite by
Fiat I thought you know I have ruled out
any other structure that you get to
wait here right yeah uh but what Grover
showed is that if I can ask about every
box in quantum superposition and then
you know take my superposition of
answers you know do some quantum
mechanical transformation to it what we
call a unitary transformation and then
ask another question and and so on and
so on then there is a way to get all or
almost all of the amplitude on to the
right answer that is on to the box with
the Golden Nugget in it by asking only
about square root of n questions right
okay so so what this means is that for
example if you had some combinatorial
search problem say an np-complete
problem if previously it would have
taken you let's say two to the 100 steps
to solve with your classical computer
well by layering Grover's algorithm on
top of what you were doing classically
typically you would be able to solve it
in about 2 to the 50 steps with a
quantum computer ok and that and that's
something I mean that will sort of
expand the frontier of you know the
sizes of problems that you can handle
and I think that absolutely would have
applications in a world with fully
scalable you know and useful quantum
computers it's just it's not the
exponential speed-up and for anyone out
there
factoring for anyone out there who knows
a little bit of quantum mechanics
studying and understanding Grover's
algorithm is way easier than Shor's
algorithm it's actually pretty stratus
true that is yeah that is true and
actually the reason for that is that
Shor's algorithm like 2/3 of it is just
classical number theory that's got
nothing to do with my mechanics right
it's just getting it into learned form
where you can then do something quantum
right
Grover's you know so what when I I so so
I do teach all of these things in an
undergraduate course you know for which
the only prerequisites are like linear
algebra and some you know classical you
know programming or you know like say a
semester of classical algorithms you
know I I teach all the quantum mechanics
that we need for the class and we do
shores and
Grover's algorithm but typically a
Shor's algorithm would be three lectures
Grover's algorithm would be one lecture
and we should also plug your book on
this side oh yeah yeah I do have a book
it's called quantum computing since
Democritus uh yeah it was published
seven years ago
it is not a popular book it is also not
a text book it is in some you know
intermediate complexity class I don't
know exactly what it is but you know
when I wrote the prospectus for the
publisher I thought of well you know
kind of like though whatever audience is
buying Penn roses books I'm hoping that
they would also buy this book some
subset thereof yes yeah yeah okay
honestly there's an a large terrain of
questions about the reality of quantum
computing and things like that but but
that's for lesser minds we have other
fish to fry
I would like to start talking to you
okay about the nature of space and time
and stuff like that so I mean it's again
maybe a little bit of a surprise that
people famous physicists like John
Prescott and Lenny Susskind who grew up
doing particle physics and and quantum
field theory and cosmology have taken to
quantum computing and quantum
information in such a strong way I mean
why do you think that you know this this
set of ideas that started by you know
how can we improve the speed at which a
computer can answer a certain kind of
question suddenly seems to be everywhere
in discussions of the nature of
space-time itself yeah okay so so I mean
I mean I have several thoughts the first
one is you know yeah you're the one
asking me about the nature of space yeah
yeah but no but my second thought was
you know the specific people you
mentioned um John Prescott 84 he we
could add raela Flom by the way right
you know these were all people who
started out in high-energy physics but
then you know very or very early so back
in the mid 90s kind of switched to
quantum computing and quantum
information you
basically you know after Shor's
algorithm came along yeah and you know I
mean I mean I know all of them so you
know I talked to them about what some of
their their reasons were and I think
mostly just it was something that was
new and exciting and where you know the
the knowledge that they had you know was
what was what was relevant it was not
the only thing that was relevant you
know computer science you know
information also was but you know you
know these these were people who knew
quantum mechanics really really well and
you know high-energy physics I mean it
is a you know it is it is one of the
great pursuits of the human species but
you know if I'm advising a student you
know on what they should specialize in
and they don't really really have their
heart set on doing high energy physics
well you know I mean I mean there is an
immense amount of brainpower you know
that is sort of being expended on you
know you know and not a huge set of
questions I'm sort of a you know a very
you know narrow you know I will say a
very tall and narrow tower of knowledge
right and you know and and and there was
an you know unbelievable success over
you know the course of the 20th century
in building up that tower you know and
now that you know we're in this world
where you know the LHC has found the
Higgs boson it hasn't found anything
else you know you know one could ask the
question of you know is you know should
we just continue trying to you know add
a millimeter to this tower you know sort
of in the way that we knew or should we
you know go down to the land and look
for what else is being built somewhere
else yeah these are these are hard you
know there's no one right answer to
these questions right there's an answer
for each individual to make for
themselves but you know but I think it
is you know it is you know a quantum
computing especially in the 90s was a
field that was just full of low-hanging
fruit and you know and I think really
you know a fundament
questions right I think that to someone
like fresco right it was clear that this
is not just a technological question
right this is not just like an
engineering design problem of build this
quantum computer this is a fundamental
question of you know does is nature
going to allow this at all right you
know can a scalable quantum computer be
built or you know is this so ridiculous
that you know we should just suppose
that there is something about quantum
mechanics that we have not yet
understood that is going to prohibit you
know getting an exponential
computational speed up in this way yeah
right you know think this I think I
understand yeah
you know I understand your point in fact
I think you're being diplomatic about it
I mean as amazing as high-energy physics
is and I'm a big fan myself it's a
mature field that has slowed down a
little bit the rate of progress but I'm
asking less about people who have
switched from high energy yeah to
quantum computers versus yeah people who
like the thing they want to understand
is still why black holes evaporate in a
certain way and they've decided that
ideas from quantum information theory
are relevant to that somehow yes right
well now that no that is a newer thing
that has happened and that's actually
right where I was headed next because
you know you know in in the 90s you know
you know people went into quantum
computing I mean III went into it in the
nineties you know and you know did not
expect that it was going to say anything
about you know about string theory about
you know black holes about space-time I
mean maybe even then I secretly hoped it
would but I had no basis for that oh
yeah right
and and I would say that within the last
eight or nine years you know something
really amazing has happened which is
that you know the the the the the things
really have circled back and you know
the people who talk about you know the
quantum gravity these days about you
know the black hole information problem
and you know about the 80s CFT you know
about a sort of holographic space-time
you know at least the ones who I talked
to they are talking about it largely in
a language of qubits and you know gates
you know quantum circuits acting on
those qubits and entanglement you know
and the the entanglement structure of
the quantum states that you get and you
know even even complexity the the
complexity of doing various tasks to
these qubits and this has been an
amazing development for me because I'm
like well now I can actually talk to you
about this stuff yeah you know this is
the language that uh you know I you know
I can I can I can parse at least half of
what you're saying and I mean you know I
mean if you look at the list of talks of
the strings conference right in recent
years I mean it is quite remarkable to
an outsider like me you know how much of
it is not explicitly about strings at
all right but is about sort of ideas
that are just as much quantum
information so you know if I had to
speculate I mean I mean I mean the the
the the way that this happened was sort
of you know it's sort of a long story
but you could say you know in some sense
it goes back to to Hawking in the 70s
you know and and bekenstein right the
story goes back to the black hole
information problem they said you know
there is this fundamental conceptual
problem about black holes and this
problem is information theoretic and
character in some sense right this you
know the the problem is you know explain
how information can come out of a black
hole you know as it needs to do in order
for the evolution of a black holes to be
unitary but as you know to be fully
compatible with quantum mechanics as we
understand it
and it was you know thinking about
matters like those that you know people
in the 70s and 80s were read to the
realization that a black hole has an
entropy not only does it have an entropy
but it has sort of the largest entropy
of any object in the in the universe of
a similar size okay yeah you know you
could say a black hole is sort of the
highest density hard disk that is
allowed by the laws of physics right
specifically it stores about 10 to the
69 bits or rather 10 to the 69 qubits
per square meter of surface area of its
event horizon I mean they wander in
their highest entropy state so it's not
a very useful or disk that's right
that's right
so it's well you know it's it's not it's
really not great for retrieving the best
that's the other problem with you know I
mean I mean you know you'd have to wait
for these bits to fizzle out and Hawking
radiation which you know might take 10
to the seventieth years or something
like that and then you know and then
they'd be in some completely scrambled
form so you know so it's not a very
useful hard disk but you know like even
just purely in a by by the lights of
like information theory or computer
science
black holes are interesting right black
holes are an extremal object and so you
know these were realizations that people
started to have in the 70s and 80s you
know I would say it was not really
connected yet to computer science I mean
it was it was certainly something that
enormous Lee intrigued me you know even
in like 2002 2003 you know I talked to
Rafael Bou so at that time you know I
talked to one maldacena ice you know and
and uh maldacena was like joking with me
about it you know a couple years ago I
go yeah you were this crazy kid and was
saying they're like complexity was
somehow going to be relevant on gravity
I was trying to be polite to you you
know
yeah but but you know I would say that
what really made it click what really
sort of made this connection happen in a
deep way a lot of it started in 2012
which is when there was this now famous
paper the amps paper you know um he
remarked Merrill polchinski and solely
that data pointed out this thing called
the firewall paradox okay and you know
this was um well it's a long story this
firewall paradox okay but the punch
basically no you can you can you know if
you're worried about how information can
come out of a black hole you're sort of
lead from there to the idea that well
you know the the information it couldn't
have gotten out from the singularity and
you know so like really what you would
like for it to have happen is that it's
sort of just fizzling off from the you
know on or very near the event horizon
right and in fact if you're an observer
outside of a black hole
well you never even see anything fall
into the black hole in the first place
right you just see it get slower and
slower and you know pancaked over the
event horizon and scrambled there and so
so an observer who's outside of a black
hole ought to have a description of
what's going on where all the bits of
information that are dropped into the
black hole are just sort of pancaked on
its horizon scrambled on the event
horizon and then come off from there and
yet an observer who falls into the black
hole has to have a completely different
picture of the same physics right for
them they have to see that the
information really has fallen in and
that there is an interior of the black
hole you know in the middle of which is
a singularity and so then these two
completely different sounding
descriptions have to be somehow dual to
each other right they have to be two
different ways of describing the same
thing so then that leads in the 90s to
this you know idea of the holographic
principle that you can have different
physical theories with different numbers
spatial dimensions but that are somehow
somehow one is just an encoding of an of
the other one so you know you can encode
everything that happens in a given
region of space by some hologram that
lives on the boundary of that region and
then you know people were you know I I
wouldn't say like a hundred percent
satisfied by all of this but you know
they thought they had kind of the broad
outlines of a solution to the black hole
information problem and then basically
in 2012 this amps paper came along and
it broke everything again that you know
if you you know write down certain
postulates that seem like they should be
clearly true like an observer who is
falling into a black hole you know
notices nothing special as they crossed
the event horizon and you know black
holes you know the from the outside
observers perspective they quickly
scramble information you know and a few
other postulates then you could write
down an experiment you know that I in
principle some observer who was outside
of a black hole could do so here's how
the experiment would work let's say
you're Alice right so you drop some
stuff into a black hole you keep track
of its exact quantum state with some
SuperDuper powerful quantum computer
right and now you wait for the black
hole to mostly but not completely
evaporate okay you know for a black hole
the you know the mass of a star this
might take ten to the sixty seven years
you know we assume that you have a
really long grant okay you collect all
of the rate the photons of Hawking
radiation that come out of the black
hole you route them all into your
quantum computer for analysis then you
do a certain measurement on those
photons that proves that they are that
they were not in a completely thermal
state in other words you know what do
and and one can argue that once the
black hole has more than
50 percent evaporated then something
special happens where you can actually
detect very subtle correlations in the
Hawking radiation that shows that you
know they were you know they actually do
encode the information that fell in to
create the black hole yes are just the
frame the freeze the phrase not
completely in a thermal State in this in
this sentence that he just said means
that it's not completely random that
there is some information encoded there
that is related to what fell in
precisely precisely you detect some
correlation with the stuff that fell in
and again this is something that in
principle you can do after the black
hole has more than halfway evaporated
yeah okay okay and and then having done
that you then immediately jump into the
black hole and you see what's on the
other side and now for reasons of
quantum field theory that you know I
don't well you know I don't I don't uh
you know I am I'm a not expert on and be
not sure if I we have time to go into
but because of the correlations that you
saw outside of the black hole you now
you know you either you know see a
complete breakdown of the rules of
quantum mechanics as you write as you
cross the event horizon or else if you
know you want quantum mechanics to still
work then you have to see a wall of
ultra high energy photons that are so
high energy that you just disintegrate
as soon as you hit the event horizon
this is what is called the the the
famous firewall and if okay and now the
bill in here actually have fallen into a
black hole but we this is one of the
times where physicists have a strong
belief that we have no empirical
justification for namely that nothing
special happens when you cause the black
hole's event horizon that's right that's
right and you know I can in in in some
sense you know you you could take the
position that just you know what happens
in a black hole stays in a black hole
right it could be any you know it could
be that like like in that movie
interstellar that you know you meet
you're wrong
relative or something right you know you
know and and you know this was you know
just like beliefs about the afterlife
this would have no consequences that at
least we could publish journal papers
about here on earth right because you
know everything is just inside the black
hole okay but you know physicists I
think very understandably you know have
have high aspirations right yeah they
would like to describe even regions of
the universe from which we can never
receive a signal okay and you know at
least classical general relativity you
know has paints this very nice picture
where you sail right past the event
horizon and nothing very special seems
to happen now to be clear you know you
do die you know after you jump into a
black hole but you're only supposed to
die when you hit the singularity right
you're not supposed to you know this so
you know you're supposed to have like
another second or whatever after you've
crossed the event horizon right you're
not supposed to die right at the event
horizon but this firewall paper was
saying well from these assumptions it
appears that you would and you know and
and this was not just some some you know
completely a you know formal question
about say the structure of the state
space right what I liked about it is
what they said here very explicitly here
is the experiment that would weed to the
problem right right and you know okay
fine it's not an experiment that maybe
we could ever practically carry out
within the lifetime of the universe but
nevertheless here is the experiment and
if you claim to understand this then you
have to be able to say what happens if
someone did that experiment right and
and this was I I would say that this was
really the watershed thing that brought
quantum information ideas into quantum
gravity you know in a really deep way
and in particular you know a year later
my friends Daniel Harlow and Patrick
Hayden I wrote an amazing paper about
the firewall paradox where they said
well you know it might be true that
if you do this crazy experiment you know
that you know and then try to jump into
a black hole to see what happened that
you would experience a firewall but how
hard would it be to do that experiment
and they gave evidence that to actually
do the quantum computation on the
hawking radiation that would detect
those correlations so detected it's not
in completely a thermal state would
require a quantum computation that you
know that would use a number of steps
that is exponential in the size of the
black hole meaning in the number of
qubits of the black hole so in other
words we'd be talking about a problem
that would take your quantum computer
not a mere ten to the sixty seven years
to solve right that is that that is but
by by our new standard that's going to
be be easy okay ten to the fifty seven
years is an easy problem okay but this
would be a hard problem meaning one that
takes two to the ten to the sixty seven
years to solve so it's really it's a
nice example because it takes us back to
the sort of realization post touring
that the question is not just the the
distinction between solvable and
unsolvable but how long it takes to
solve things and so once you appreciate
that you might have some really strong
beliefs in something but if those
beliefs could in principle be violated
but only by things that would take way
way way longer than the age of the
universe to happen maybe you're not
bothered so much and that's exactly what
complexity theory is all about exactly
now this is you know this is somewhat
controversial right so I mean some
people said well who cares if the
computation takes this you know huge
amount of time that's merely a practical
issue right but as horribly when hate
and pointed out one thing that it means
is that you could not have made a dent
in this computation before the black
hole would have long ago evaporated
anyway yeah right which means that then
there's nothing to jump into which means
that maybe then there's no paradox right
and yeah you could think about well what
what if you did it for
really really tiny black hole for which
you know this exponential scaling
wouldn't matter but for a really really
tiny black hole we didn't really expect
classical general relativity and quantum
field theory to work well anyway right
so you know I think it is plausible that
that sort of you know the the you know
like I get like they're you know I think
okay well let me put it this way
you know if someone said it's okay for
there to be a contradiction in the laws
of physics as long as it takes
exponential time to discover it I would
not agree with that right I would say
that that sounds like nonsense okay
but that's not what Harlow and Hayden
and we're saying okay they were saying
something more subtle that you know
there are contradictions in the
affective theories right that we you
know normally work do you provided that
we now have to ultimately be superseded
by a quantum theory of gravity right and
it might be that some of these you know
problems with effective field theories
you would find them not by going to an
enormous Lehigh energy or to an enormous
ly tiny distance but by going to a
regime of extreme computational
complexity okay but you know if it would
take an exponential computation to
uncover the breakdown of effective field
theory then you know we have we do have
a reason you know for sort of trusting
our effective field theory and
quote-unquote normal situations yeah and
I don't think sadly we don't have time
to go into into the details but I think
that since then since that watershed
moment there's really been yes wonderful
importing of all sorts of ideas from
quantum information and just sort of the
rapid locator science I mean I know even
I've written papers involving things
like quantum circuits and tensor
networks and yeah if like that and it's
really really rated mature field I know
yeah right so then I mean I mean I mean
I'm Lenny Susskind you know became sort
of a a sort of prophet of this movement
right and you know as he as he's all
often a prophet for whatever he believes
in at the given moment right but you
know I would say he became
far more gung-ho than I am about you
know complexity is the future of physics
you know I was the one saying like you
know slow down yeah you know I wouldn't
go that far
right but you know the connection has
gone a lot further now like in this this
80s CFT correspondence where you
literally use circuit complexity as sort
of the thing that is holographically
dual through some geometric quantity
like the volume of a wormhole you know
and and that might not that that might
be because you know Lenny thinks that
it's because circuit complexity really
does have fundamental importance in
physics you know just like entropy or
like energy I'm not willing to go as far
as he does there but I say that you know
nevertheless it is the best placeholder
that anyone can come up with yeah or you
know whatever quantity really is dual to
these volumes of wormholes and things
like that it I mean it is great stuff
it's it's right there on the cutting
edge and I think we're gonna have to end
because the other topics I wanted to
talk about include words like freewill
and consciousness and oh I can't imagine
that we would get anything interesting
said in less than an hour each so we'll
save that for a future episode
many people let people absorb but the
complexity and quantumness of what we
already talked about awesome if you
invite me for a podcast about free will
I will I will choose to participate so
you say this is a universe that gets to
decide alright Scott Aaronson thanks so
much for being on the mindscape pod all
right thanks so much Scott
pleasure as always
[Music]
you
[Music]